[Music]
thank you
any part of their workflow
here it is you want to see the live demo
yeah you pimp install it and usually
that's all you have to do okay you're
done
so you draw whatever you want and it's
gonna feel it's gonna make you look like
it's a masterpiece
and in this process we're going to turn
it into a trackable surface okay so uh
the image in the prompt has been sent to
control next and let's go yeah
the name of the game 20 000 users 5
million images made in three months and
uh it's wild man it's a great great time
to be alive beautiful we are also
looking for starting open sourcing
models
[Music]
the event is awesome I invited six
people when I started it was like I was
around two three hundred quickly became
3000 and I saw six of my friends here
awesome what's your favorite uh demo
that you've seen so far I like the
alpaca it's not a weird demo but I like
the alpaca Booth yeah I'm a huge fan of
apolinario so it was amazing to see all
of his artworks in here uh yeah that was
my favorite one for sure
all right all right what do you think
about what do you think about open
source
[Music]